morbius may be a solo movie for the
marvel anti-hero but it references at
least five other villains from
spider-man's rogues gallery did you
catch them all these are the small
details you missed in morbius
let's get this out of the way morbius is
not in the marvel cinematic universe and
it's not produced by marvel studios it's
a sony product part of its own universe
of marvel characters namely most of the
marvel comics characters mainly
associated with spider-man there's only
three movies in this universe the two
venom movies and now morbius but that
doesn't mean more movies in sony's own
series aren't on the way an early
conversation between nichols and milo
sees the wealthy villain explain that he
recently crossed paths with a certain
russian gentleman which is why he's
hired bodyguards to look after him he
doesn't go into more detail but it seems
likely that this mysterious russian he's
referring to is actually craven the
hunter sure there have been a few
different russian villains to grace the
pages of the spider-man comics over the
years but considering sony is working on
a craven the hunter movie it seems
likely that this is a reference to the
iconic hunter craven's real name is
sergey kravinov and he's been a
long-standing spider-man villain first
going up against the wall crawler back
in 1964's amazing spider-man issue
number 15. craven has gone after the
spider for decades and he even dons the
costume himself in the iconic story line
craven's last hunt to prove that he can
best the hero by being a better
vigilante than him the craven the hunter
movie started production in london in
march 2022 as fans spotted aaron taylor
johnson filming a car chase through the
streets the film is currently slated for
a january 13th 2023 release so it'll be
quite some time before fans get an
official look at the spin-off movie
however it's likely he'll be a morally
ambiguous anti-hero rather than a
full-blown bad guy
one of the key locations in the film is
horizon labs where morbius looks after
children with the same blood disorder
that he has while also carrying out his
research into curing the condition this
isn't just a random name horizon labs
has been a huge part of the spider-man
comics in the last decade as peter
parker worked there during dan's slot's
run on the character it's a place for
gifted scientists to work on the most
cutting edge technology and ideas
without the restraints of having to
pitch them to a board of directors
morbius also works for horizon in the
comics and he is the one who creates a
serum that saves everyone in new york
when the events of spider island turn
everyone into giant arachnids but he's
not the only villain to grace the
laboratory's halls otto octavius aka dr
octopus also works for the company after
he transfers his consciousness into
peter's brain in amazing spider-man
issue number 700 and he uses horizon as
a way of developing new technology for
his own heroic career it's also worth
pointing out that horizon also has a
floating laboratory on a boat called the
zenith so they can also operate in
international waters but it's got a
different name in morbius
a key sequence in the film sees morbius
undergo his experimental procedure with
the help of his love interest
colleague martine bancroft on a huge
ship way off the coast of long island
this is because the procedure isn't
approved by the united states food and
drug association so they won't be
prosecuted just for carrying it out it
all goes south when morbius transforms
into a blood-sucking monster and
slaughters the gang of mercenaries that
they've hired to protect them
awkward
but the ship itself is called the myrnow
a neat reference to the famed director f
w murnow who helmed the first ever
vampire movie 1922's nosferatu the
german silent film is an unofficial
adaptation of graham stoker's dracula
and follows similar story beats to the
original tale including scenes where
count orlock kills the crew of a ship as
he travels from transylvania to germany
although morbius is far from a
traditional vampire story with the main
character explicitly being a living
vampire it's nice to see an homage to
the very first cinematic bloodsucker in
this unorthodox modern day take
just in case it isn't clear that morbius
takes place in the same universe as the
hugely successful venom franchise the
film spells it out for the audience a
couple of times over the course of
morbius's adventure when the authorities
first find the murnau with a horde of
bled-out bodies on board fbi agent
rodriguez notes to agent stroud that
they haven't had a weird case like this
since oh
around fall 2018
we haven't had anything this good since
that thing in san francisco
it's an obvious reference to eddie brock
and venom demonstrating that the
symbiotic anti-hero isn't exactly a
secret on the streets the lethal
protector got into even more trouble in
the 2021 sequel let there be carnage
when he went up against the twisted
cletus cassidy and when morbius takes
over an underground lab used by a
counterfeit gang he jokingly intimidates
one of them by making a reference to the
lethal protector
i
am
this means that news about venom has
spread across the country although it's
not quite clear what the public knows
about the symbiote other than the fact
that he occasionally eats criminals and
fights other alien goo monsters in san
francisco it's also not clear why
michael morbius knows venom's cool line
either maybe you saw the movie
we
are them
it'll be interesting to see whether
venom and morbius will ever share the
screen together but sony seems dead set
on delivering a sinister six team-up
movie at some point venom isn't usually
a member of that team at least not in
the comics but it's still a possibility
that they might team up on screen
sony might not have the rights to the
character but morbius writers matt sasma
and burke sharpless managed to squeeze a
hulk reference into the movie
nonetheless although morbius's
transformation cures him of his blood
disorder and grants him enhanced speed
and strength as well as unique
echolocation ability it also means that
he has to feed on blood so that he
doesn't revert back to his sickly self
he manages to sustain himself on
artificial blood for a little while but
it just doesn't last as long as the real
thing and when morbius finds himself
wrongfully locked up in the manhattan
detention facility for the murder of a
nurse in horizon labs he starts to get a
little angry he makes it clear to
rodriguez and shroud how desperate he is
for blood saying you won't like me when
i'm hungry while he doesn't say these
days the line is a definite callback to
the incredible hulk tv series from the
1970s starring bill bixby as dr david
bruce banner and lou ferrigno as the
titular green monster
don't make me angry
you wouldn't like me when i'm angry
it effectively became banner's
catchphrase so much so that the actual
mcu has been going out of its way not to
say it that said the mcu does have its
own version of the iconic line with
bruce revealing in the avengers
i'm always angry
just to reassure fans that this movie is
indeed spider-man related the daily
bugle newspaper shows up throughout the
film and its headlines are often easter
eggs the first one makes a reference to
a rhino getting loose from a zoo this
doesn't exactly confirm that the famous
spider-man villain necessarily shares a
universe with morbius since the headline
sounds like it involves a literal rhino
rather than the super supervillain of
the same name it's still a cute
reference the rhino is another of
spider-man's more famous villains in the
comics arguably more well-known than
morbius himself he's known for his brute
strength and the fact that he dresses up
in a rhino costume the rhino previously
smashed his way into live action in the
amazing spider-man 2 where he was played
by paul giamatti he probably would have
played a part in the original sinister
six movie that sony was developing with
drew goddard before sony reset its
spider-man plans after the movie
underperformed
the second reference on the daily
bugle's front page reads black cat
friend or foe which seemingly confirms
that felicia hardy exists here too the
character previously appeared in the
amazing spider-man 2 played by rogue one
star felicity jones in a minor role she
briefly shows up as one of the
assistants working at ozcorp before
harry osborne notices her and hires her
as his personal assistant she was also
presumably going to have a larger role
in that universe before sony scrapped
the third installment of the amazing
spider-man black cat is an iconic
character in the spider-man mythos
largely because she's one of the
webslinger's frequent love interests the
burglar first appears in 1979's amazing
spider-man issue number 194 when she
hatches a plan to break her dying father
out of prison it also establishes that
anyone who crosses her falls foul of her
bad luck riffing off the common
superstition regarding actual black cats
it's highly likely that black cat will
show up in a future film with sony
already having at least one movie for
the character in development the studio
was originally planning to use the femme
fatale alongside mercenary silver sable
in a team-up adventure titled silver and
black from director gina prince bythwood
the movie was set aside and the director
moved on to other projects however the
filmmaker told looper in 2020 that she'd
love to return to the characters with
the script she wrote
but wait there's a third daily bugle
headline referencing yet another member
of spidey's rogues gallery chameleon's
great escape suggests that demetrius
mirdanikov has already had a brush with
the authorities and has even managed to
escape prison if it's on the front page
of the bugle although many of the
webslinger's villains take inspiration
from animals chameleon doesn't actually
dress up like the reptile he's named
after instead he's a master of disguise
and can impersonate anyone he likes to
carry up robberies and assassinations
surprisingly fans might have already
seen a version of chameleon in live
action with a dimitri showing up in
spider-man far from home as one of nick
fury's associates
that
is dmitry
he's played by newman a car in the mcu
but he doesn't actually get to do
anything comparable to his comic book
origins chameleon first shows up in
1962's amazing spider-man issue number
one where he steals highly classified
missile plans and frames the titular
hero for the crime the white mask
wearing villain will next be seen in the
craven the hunter solo movie this time
played by fred heshinger it's worth
pointing out that chameleon is actually
craven's half-brother so hopefully that
dynamic gets the spotlight in the 2023
movie
it just wouldn't be a comic book movie
if the big bad didn't go after the
hero's love interest in the dramatic
finale and morbius is no exception
unfortunately milo catches martine
bancroft and forces her to cry out for
her moody vampire bow in a bid to kick
start the predictable final battle a
hero and a villain with the same set of
superpowers
groundbreaking anyway he ultimately
leaves martine bleeding out on a rooftop
for morbius to find her in a generous
act of sacrifice she lets the good
doctor drink her blood so he's fully
powered to kill milo but before she dies
a drop of morbius's own blood drips into
her mouth and she licks her teeth with
it weird but hey she's dying so he won't
judge one of the final moments of the
film sees martine wake up with bright
red eyes implying that she's returned as
a vampire this could be picked up in a
morbius sequel and there's a precedent
for it in the 30th issue of the comic
book fear in which martine is turned
into a vampire by an enemy of morbius
although she becomes a living vampire
like morbius her newfound abilities make
her aspire to be a true vampire like
dracula
oh dear
hello martine vancroft and bring on
morbius 2.
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one